oui bonjour bienvenue intel à la fois je
me présente michel audet de la nation
innu et québécoise aujourd'hui j'ai
envie de vous partager plusieurs perles
de petites comme des grandes
on parle beaucoup de réconciliation 1 la
commission vérité réconciliation voire
requérir beaucoup de témoignages des
pauses en rapport avec plusieurs
recommandations d appel à l'action pour
trouver des manières et les façons de
faire pour réconcilier un passé
plusieurs peuples des institutions le
milieu la société et ainsi de suite
réconcilier je vous avouerai que pour
moi réconciliation c'était difficile par
moment puis par moments c'était comme
naturel de l'embrasser ou de l'endosser
le mois de juin
célébration de l'histoire des premiers
peuples
le 21 juin journée nationale des nations
ici au canada les premières nations les
métis et les inuits
tout ça dans une célébration pour ma
part le mot dieu a commencé un peu pas
mal rohff c'était difficile
si vous vous souvenez de ma dernière
chronique je les trouve étoffement début
de juin juste pour vous dire un peu
pourquoi alors on nous dit on célèbre
alors qu'en même temps nous étions pour
certains d'entre nous et ceux et celles
qui ont suivi sa via les réseaux sociaux
et les médias la famille dubé et chaque
coin d'écouter attentivement tous les
témoignages
lors des audiences du coroner suite au
décès de joyce et chaque coin c'est un
moment difficile
on apprend aussi la découverte macabre
des 215 peut-être lumière dans un ancien
site à camelot alors de passionnantes
évidemment et d'écoles résidentiel ça
fait mal et le 3 juin on nous annonce
encore une fois c'est le deuxième
anniversaire du
dépôt de l'amf à dole enquête nationale
sur les femmes et filles autochtones
assassinées et disparues
donc des moments qui sont difficiles des
moments qui nous rappelle un lourd passé
mais une chance
une chance que beaucoup de gens de nos
nations
beaucoup d'alliances à travers le canada
et au québec vont nous rappeler le
travail que ces gens ont fait pour un
projet de loi autour de la déclaration
des nations unies sur les droits des
peuples autochtones sur un projet de loi
le projet de loi 79 ici au québec pour
faire en sorte que les familles puissent
avoir des informations personnelles des
renseignements personnels suit alors la
disparition de leur bébé de leurs
enfants dans un hôpital ou dans une
communauté religieuse
à une certaine époque alors plusieurs
années plus tard en fait on va permettre
à ces familles de leur dire ce qui est
arrivé alors on connaît on reconnaît et
on réconcilie un passé douloureux vers
une guérison personnelle et collective
l'on peut parler on peut parler de
réconciliation on peut célébrer je
réalise aussi que le mois de juin c'est
les feux sur la littérature autochtone
dont beaucoup de libraires à travers le
canada vont vous proposer de la lecture
de nos auteurs et autres crise issue du
peuple métis et nouer premières nations
alors c'est un cadeau qu'on se fait
collectivement mais le cadeau le plus
cher pour moi le plus précieux à travers
les projets de loi à travers les
commissions à travers les initiatives
comme la ville à la lecture qu'on
propose
j'aimerais beaucoup que les
gouvernements à travers le canada que
nos nations puissent collaborer de façon
intense
il est solide pour refaire l'histoire
l'histoire cette fois ci en co
construction
je sais je répète mais c'est important
pour moi qu'on apprenne de la petite
enfance jusqu'à l'université
l'histoire de nos nations québec québec
est un bon mourinoux moi je pense pas qu
ont été franches et les nations pour qui
ont accueilli ma moitié
nos enceintes je pense qu'on était super
sympathiques et accueillants parce qu'on
leur a dit que bach qu'abc débarqué de
vos bâtons c'est plus tard qu'on s'est
penché et pour se réconcilier
je vous dis refaire l'histoire mais
aussi connaître reconnaître et là on va
pouvoir parler d'une réelle
réconciliation
sur ce je vous souhaite un bon mois de
juin beau 21 juin et ça fait beaucoup de
perles que je vous partage mais c'est
quelque chose d'important et je suis
convaincu moi je sais j'ai besoin de
vous pour ce changement nous avons
besoin de vous pour ce changement est
bien sûr je sais vous avez besoin de
nous et nous sommes là y'a mai